great thank you yes sir and I'm here
with Fabiano Carana Fabi congratulations
you made it you won the game today and
the two previous games finished in the
draw let's see the last one was really
crazy I thought you were in trouble I
also thought I was in trouble yeah no I
think I was losing but I I think I
defended it very well even low on time
yeah this position didn't look that nice
because he controls C file and I don't
know yeah he he always controls a C file
and my knight is very bad the only thing
I have for me is that his Knight is also
bad for the moment but if he gets to G3
I I resign yeah but you managed to play
this Knight C4 fantastic move which
immediately yeah changed the whole
situation I think this was tricky okay I
wasn't sure I could be losing on the
spot with this move um yeah there were
some lines I was a bit surprised by Rook
C3 because I thought uh that other move
is like Rook C7 is very critical of
course did you did you see this um funny
line that Queen B3 and Rook C6 I thought
yeah Rook C6 yes and actually computer
Peter sh suggested Queen E1 and then
Queen E2 and you go for the check I
didn't see Queen E1 that's interesting
no I was thinking Queen A6 and queen A4
okay I'm uh yeah I wasn't sure if I'm
surviving or not but at least I'm not
losing on the spot but I was very happy
when I got this okay Queen B2 I thought
anyway he can play Rook C7 but I was
surprised by this very surprised because
well first the point I was quite happy
about was that there is this this little
tactic okay it's kind of cute uh and I
win an exchange W so he played Queen E4
okay Knight C4 I thought it's a draw
just missed it this Knight C4 move yeah
I wasn't sure but I like I thought okay
we're going to make a draw he'll do this
I'll do this and yeah yeah Perpetual
check or something like that and I
thought if he wants to play on okay he
can play A5 but it's extremely risky to
play A5 because then he's really stuck
so he played this and I realized that
I'm getting checkmated like Rook B6
Queen E7 A5 Queen B7 so okay Rook D7 I
need it to play but it looked quite
solid at least and I was happy that for
example if A5 here where he block the
the queen side that I probably have
um uh well no sorry 94 I think this is
critical and Rook C7 I was very happy
with this move because if A5 then I have
this Knight D2 yeah Knight D2 is was and
queen check and I don't think I have
more than draw but okay draw is anyway I
was quite happy with at this moment uh
and and I thought okay maybe I have some
other move but I didn't really see it so
I was going to go for this and then he
surprised me with King H2 because I had
seen that this F5 is um suddenly playing
for a win like wherever his Knight moves
I have A5 and he can't get to my king
anymore because the Rook on C7 is
performing a really nice job so I I
thought it's still a complete mess of
course I have 50 seconds I don't know
Rook C4 is it working here no nothing
like that yes yeah there's like this
queen A5 I mean I I didn't really I
think I saw this possibility but I
wasn't worried because like let's say in
this position I I have a draw yeah in my
hand like I can play c c C3 cb3 and it's
a draw and so was his last chance to to
make a draw or something yeah probably
probably it is a draw it does feel like
white should not be losing in this
position where he is of material for the
moment and position is where opened but
he went straight for a line which I
actually had while he was thinking I
kind of was thinking about it so I I
very quickly made these moves because I
expected this it looks very natural what
he's doing cuz here like he gets this he
takes here he takes B7 and I don't know
it's a lot of Pawns I wasn't wasn't so
sure about that one so so I saw this and
the point is of course that if he takes
then I don't care about the queen side
so much it's just that I play H5 and and
win his Knight and okay Knight H1 is
basically resignation but yeah it it was
a very lucky Escape yeah but before you
missed also a great chance against
Wesley so let's have a look at this game
hope we have some time for that um you
want me to relive my painful yes yes yes
of course we have to check this mode I
mean I just was wondering what did you
miss exactly like G5 or or which I'll
tell you so I just I just came here so
of course like we I I I feel like I
played quite accurately of course I
don't know if everything I did was
correct but it felt like all of these
moves I made were quite accurate and
once I saw this yeah this moment I saw
that like I have F5 and King G8 and I
thought game is over I saw Queen B1 and
like I thought everything wins in this
position like literally everything wins
okay Queen H6 for example is basically
immediate resignation because he has to
give his check and then Queen f8 and any
Queen trade my C Pawn promotes okay
Queen F7 is very good F5 and if I don't
want to calculate a single thing just
Queen E8 and he resigns just prevent
this checks yeah just stop checks and
he's checkmated and trade of Queens also
wins for black so I I think that maybe
he won't resign at this moment but it's
actually not too it's not like it's too
early to resign so basically I just
calculated up to this moment and I I
thought in my calculations like can do
this I realized I blunder check made in
one move ah this is what you missed okay
uhhuh yeah I I basically I missed this
queen G4 so I thought okay also King F5
wins I was what I was thinking like
everything wins but King F4 super safe
and uh then I realized that I'm lucky
not to lose my first thought was oh my
God I'm losing because I lose my Rook
yeah um yeah this was terrible and then
also against Ray I think I had serious
winning chances despite probably being
losing as well uh against Yan I I had a
complete meltdown yeah just plus eight
out of the opening yeah I mean yeah I
saw this game I mean I think you have
some kind of shaky start and how can you
explain this do you feel a bit tired
after Grand swis or I just blend every
game I'm blundering I like my players
extremely poor I have to say uh every
game I think has been poor except maybe
which game did I play
well no
no remember
yes some doubts okay P thank you so much
and I wish you all the best tomorrow I
mean already 50% not so bad no 50% is a
miracle and I should celebrate tonight
see you tomorrow and we're back to the
studio thank thank you Anastasia